the jurogan experience it's kind of
stunning being spoken well you see how
little england is
yeah you know that i mean it makes sense
what you're talking about with pirates
that like they had to be the most
horrific monsters to try to control the
empire well it's also insane by the way
so
i did this special in um spain so i i i
and i love history so
do you know what year they finally
unified spain
where they got rid of the moors and they
finally
the castilians kind of pieced together
what we consider
modern day spain do you know what year
they did that
1492.
the year
that columbus so they literally finally
kicked the moors out by the way were
really
they were really not nice the moors are
evil people well no no they were not
nice to the moors or the jews like they
got the the moors though they were
conquerors themselves they were
conquerors but like everybody was back
but like the the
i mean i performed in morocco it's like
amazing to think that like
you know we we think of the colonizers
as these europeans but the arabs were
colonizers too they colonized morocco
so like there's the berbers
and i'm sure i'm pronouncing that wrong
that
so the moroccans
that were in
spain
were part of you know when muhammad and
all these guys
rose up the great
arab power
was
they took over and they got all all the
way into spain and stuff like that but
it's insane to think that
i mean this was a joke that i had when i
went to spain like spain took
all the gold
all the gold from central and south
america
all of it so like there wasn't really
that much gold in north america
there was gold in central and south
america and the spain took it all
and they spent it
and so one of my jokes when i was in
spain i'm like where's the gold where is
it
you guys like they literally
like one of the things they did is they
built a navy and they got their ass
kicked by the british
you know so it's it's really fascinating
to see what
how quick these empires come and how
quick they disappear yeah and that's the
strange thing about where we are today
is that we want to think that the united
states is going to be around forever
and that you know
the
power and influence we enjoy over the
rest of the world will continue this way
and there's no way would ever live under
the thumb of a ruthless dictator like
they did you know back in the day in
this part of the world or that part of
the world like that's been the standard
way that human beings have governed
forever yeah the romans were like we're
good no one's going to take over yeah
come on we got it yeah the greeks the
same way i mean they started with
democracy yeah right and it all [ __ ]
fell apart i mean the romans were like
so confident they're like you know
constantine's like you know what i don't
even want to do rome anymore let's go
over to what's present-day istanbul like
he switched the capital of rome
that's insane
it's it's kind of like
if a president was like you know what i
think our capital should now be in uh
let's now put it in vancouver yeah
like in a different country right this
roman empire
it was named after a city rome and he
moved it to an you know essentially asia
it's like insane why did he go there
i think that objects
i think that i think that was
that was modern maybe i don't know oh
interesting i don't know i dan carlin
would know yeah he'd be the guy how does
that guy know so much he's just
consuming yeah well he works so hard on
his show to call his show a podcast and
to call this a podcast is really kind of
hilarious because this is like we did
zero preparation i haven't seen you in
two years yeah yeah we talked like
through text messages only and then also
we're sitting there talking we have no
idea what we're going to talk about and
we've been talking for hours
dan carlin when he does a two-hour
podcast he will research that for months
months and months like well he'll do a
thing like the wrath of the con which is
a spectacular five piece series on
genghis khan
when he did that it took like six months
to prepare
wow yeah and then he puts them out and
you can get them for a dollar they cost
a dollar each and it is like literally
some of the most spectacular historical
entertainment you'll ever get in your
life it's educational there's an
enthusiasm to how he does it he's
amazing he's an ama and he's so humble
too he always says he's not a historian
like picture yeah he always says that
stop saying that
he's have you met him i haven't met him
he's a great guy too he's been on the
podcast a couple times and so what is
so the length of his podcast are
astronomical yeah they're like four
hours poor part one yeah of caesar
conquers the world and you're like what
he's like
let me quote from this book that i read
i'm like dude i haven't
like reading this dense information he
goes sophocles wrote this thing and
you're like how do you know that
yeah he and he covers so many different
topics he had a great piece on martin
luther and the invention of lutheranism
and
the
time in history where making a version
of the bible that was phonetically
readable that people could understand
like a phonetic interpretation of the
bible where you could say the word like
that didn't exist like they they all
read the bible in latin and if you
didn't understand latin you most people
didn't read right you were at the whim
of the priests and martin luther came
along and said actually what god said
like she could probably interpret it
yourself and not leave it to these
people
and like they came real close to killing
him a few times for that
it is amazing how consistently
uh the messages and the teachings of
jesus are like like humans can't grasp
it like they're like way off
like oh we're supposed to take care of
the poor we're supposed to help the
needy we're supposed to do all this and
people were like does that mean i should
get another car like we don't
we don't even come close i'm gonna get a
jesus tattoo
i mean like
we don't
and i'm talking about people that uh you
know embrace the christian faith yes
like get it wrong i'm not talking about
people like i don't believe in that
stuff right
people who proclaim to be christian
again humans are pretty dumb